oh dude baby you know this is a special
episode firing the kid Brian kid
counting his [ __ ]
TV show trials absolute trash right no
it's bad
which one is it which one of these which
one should which shitty spin-off is he
doing now who knows he plays in a coach
with Rick if I don't know dude but no
gym teacher this guy's the wards they'll
worse I'm glad I'm here so I decide to
fill his chair with Bryan Callen and
then of course we we filled Brian
Collins chair with the red rock that's
right all right the red rocket tour is
coming in 2020 come on what's up bro
what's up baby it shows what's up baby
Doug trying to do it and then we got to
me one of the greatest comedians alive
right now
hey Andrew Schultz we play oh thank you
very all the way from New York man yeah
you know I didn't know that that uh
Santino and Cowan had like a friendly
beef hmm hmm it's hilarious it's not
friendly anymore
apparently not you know we were on stage
at our show
the other day at the store in the main
room yes auntie you know Santino is a
passionate fiery guy the most fun hey
someone who just goes so how do you
really feel about kaolin he says that
the Santino and it sent to you know just
sort of ripping like what bro he's like
going is like his material as days look
like I let me take the microphone away I
go for two people here was lighting him
up I feel like you're that way with
everybody except me really except for
you yeah but I but I do that with Calum
because I just his little cocky attitude
he's got to way too much attitude when
he comes in the green room he's got way
too much attitude he prances around like
he owns the place I don't like it he
feels money a lot like the Lea flashes
money yeah but it's different because
it's fun yeah Callan does it and it
makes me so [ __ ] mad dude I want to
choke him out and kill him as a little
skinny neck I'm back to thinking this is
real yeah I think I was right the things
he was saying weren't like it's personal
oh yeah it was really it was like his
hairs then you like why would you even
mention
[Laughter]
she also felt like last night in the
belly room that stand up on the spot was
made for you man dude I love that show
shots
Jeremiah yes so dope I love weird was it
though so if you were there last night
Cynthia but the way they did it you know
I've done it yeah yeah Jeremiah shows
great ami centros doing their thing
where they have a celebrity who has a
earpiece in and then people feeding them
Joe oh it's from Spade show with a coach
you stand up yes so they had it would go
legit comic like Andrew celebrity comic
celebrity comic but the crowd was like
who the celebrity who is the celebrity
this black guy where I for the straight
guy black guy first I would go down
south you know people just way more
friendly and heard him say something I
didn't know he was saying Queer Eye for
the straight guy I thought he's like I'm
the queer guy because he said hi my name
is whatever out of the queer guy and I'm
like is Spade telling him to just like
oh thanks prank and [ __ ] but there was
one guy I want to say who cuz I don't
know what they're gonna do with it but
he was he wouldn't say the stuff he go
nope not saying it he would say that out
loud
yeah he's going Cesar Millan yeah he
wouldn't do it yo mmm no wait I don't
understand what do you mean he would say
no in the middle of the [ __ ] yeah he
like where they're going I don't know
thought it was maybe two offense dude
you got into someone that there's the
kid that's his name right there you just
had a mo come tomorrow around was that
him yeah that's the guy I don't know if
that's nice
dick was in everybody's face in the
front row kymaro Brown he's a big guy is
he a big boy
not small jeans were I've never seen
Tyler jeez oh wait and sees him on the
dog guy though I miss Cesar Millan I
would love that yeah yeah I like him
want to participate
I guess not was in having it for the
most part I mean would any of you do
that what do you mean like right like
I'll have somebody in your ear like
telling you what the whole point is that
people you they're doing that too whole
point is to people that aren't staying
idea chocolate le what I say and I'll do
one joke and I'll walk if I wasn't it
if I wasn't a stand-up I get that I get
the bit right they had hot Instagram
models go up there yeah there Chuck
Liddell do it they had because they
don't you stand up that makes that's
funny to be like fed lines from
professional they have the two uh
property brothers the twins yeah them do
it yeah yeah but as a stand up know you
would never but I'm even a not stand up
and be like let me just learn one joke
and then I'll go up and I'll tell it and
then I'll get off but they're out there
for a while why are they doing that
that's gonna one of them one of them was
good I got to tell you didn't grow the
Instagram model you'd have to look it up
on Spade show that did it secret stand
up is what it's called with Whitney
Whitney Houston Whitney Houston was
there no one when Whitney Cummings does
not that's something we did it was space
in an Instagram model man they murder
loved her the jokes were fire all right
fine so like it works especially you see
a hot chick no Chuck Liddell's was funny
to Charlotte McKinney that's her right
there
unlike South yeah let's you know who
also did really well with swaggy swaggy
P we're from the arms in it Nick Young
crushed I love him bro you love swag I
love strike GB I got a fan of them too I
did a show with him we did the show
where me and him sat in a hot tub this
is legit we sat in a hot tub drinking
Coronas yeah on uh what's uh what's the
chemin cerca de Mayo no I know we did
the show years before he did his show I
was gonna say we sat in a hot tub and
we're doing the same his producer goes
hey don't mention the DeAngelo Russell
thing yeah
he's like do not mention and I go yeah
respect I won't I'm not gonna step on
his toes yeah we get in the tub no [ __ ]
yeah we're chatting he's laughing I
would get up right away he says it huh
he's like and he's like you know what I
say
snitches get stitches I'll bury a
[ __ ] I was like look to the
producer and he's just shaking his head
and I'm like I didn't say [ __ ] dude he's
off and I go I go you don't like
snitches he goes nod they know who they
are and they know exactly where they are
and I know where they are - and I
whoa I was smiling the whole time I was
like Oh GAD um this is right after a hat
like right we shot that show right after
Thank You Co so I was worried he was you
know but we they let us release it he
signed off he didn't care at all he
doesn't care about anything
cuz that's why I love that yeah yeah and
yeah D'Angelo Russell like had
recordings of it and he snitched on him
he had a Rick he had like a recording of
them in the room I think or something
right - yeah yes I thought about getting
[ __ ] and I think it all leaked and he
has always at the at the crux of it
right for some reason well he was the
one that was enough oh I thought he was
not recorded through and then bear down
like his Instagram right I think he
posts on snapchat or some [ __ ] I
obviously was a mistake I don't think he
was really he's your friend
yeah boys ball in D'Angelo well no now
he's in oh oh that's right he left yeah
you guys know Paula now yeah yeah he's
really good I think oh who could who
could definitely you can hoop this kid
can hoop thanks for the invite by the
way in Montreal to play in a basketball
league these guys didn't even [ __ ]
ever I invited you yeah AFL they invite
you these I see I go to I know you did I
know but I go down the gym to lift I
feel like I'm not I go down to lift in
these guys won't come on a basketball
jerseys I'm like oh thanks to the
advanced well Jersey
yes they do this thing where it's like
live yeah it's like full three on six
it's weird Canadians are weirdos bro
yeah just like a comedy was a Comedy
Festival game right so it was like you
as Canada versatile was handling stuff
yeah yeah Canada versus the world
yeah the world one who's your TV one
come on Broadway around was me Rafa you
know Rafi I know nothing about the dude
he can who he can who he's built like
you oh wait the straight Brazilian guy
you know I mean he's straight from
Brazil ok dude how many queer eyes do we
have on this
yeah I do know him he's great he's great
22 he's a B so he who else is on the
team hey who there's a few other folks
I'm forgetting writing like that but we
uh but yeah I was a funnel again no I'll
do it next time I want to do it but
how're you guys doing jfl in Vancouver
that I'll be in Vancouver are you going
yeah they already know you are you not
going I'm gonna this weekend oh you're
not yeah no no no we're done yeah we're
doing Vancouver this weekend I think
what her is doing it
yeah Brit was so surprised I was like
I'm surprised really well most guys will
do jfl Montreal yeah and in Toronto I
did tour unit Toronto right no you
didn't do it I did Toronto yeah I felt
promoted my Toronto dates I guess didn't
exist they were their tie you into it I
don't even know how it works I don't
even know why we need a promoter I'm
doing the promoter yeah I know no I
don't make the whole thing is really
weird though I don't even know who's
doing it bro I think it's Tim Hortons
promotes the whole thing I think I've
caught there's a coffee shop that they
do I don't know I don't know I'm good at
off you get a free twigs in Europe right
yeah so like your agent books another
agent to book your gigs in Europe right
yeah I remember when my and I love my
agent shouts is he - he's the man but I
remember when he explained this I'm like
so what the [ __ ] do I need you yeah what
I'd steal they got direct yeah like I
can email him yeah and say Scotland yeah
dude
that's what that's there get your day
you're taking away their the middleman
the agents are that's why they're
[ __ ] up I know that guy that knows
the guy they're to God but and now those
guys are done like they what is it Burke
did that deal Burke did did some deal
that's gonna change a lot I think what's
gonna happen is these like are you
allowed to say the deal I know the deal
are you allowed to say it I don't know I
don't know either maybe not
I'd only Andrews ever not said anything
because he's not allowed to say it I
like bird you got ten million dollars I
like
for his touring rights I like Bert he's
a good guy but they like give you a face
like getting a guarantee guarantee your
tickets anything they take care of
everything they're booking the dates
they're booking everything so once you
do that if his agent handed him over to
them his agents a [ __ ] yeah cuz why
would you hand someone over to someone
that makes you completely unnecessary
right and it's like why would I give you
tell me anything so I said why would you
ever do that it's just odd right yeah it
doesn't make you think that the future
is gonna be all these venues that we all
play the same venue it's like it's AEG
or like Live Nation all these venues are
gonna just go well we'll just booked
you're touring and then we'll go okay
yeah well it's kind of like it's kind of
like how uh what's our call took over
Radio completely what do they call it
Clear Channel like those guys just beat
up at ate up everything I own and
control everything any radio station you
go to now you know these nuclear they
own everything Club with all their rules
apply they're pretty much like the big
double down on radio
hard really hard that hard but podcasts
one tried that with podcasting same
title yeah they try to eat every yeah
doesn't work had I I'm like last night I
had a very uncomfortable situation where
at the club yeah what happened I I did
that he's laugh and right now I already
I it's got a beautiful I did stand
whatever I do stand up about yeah
Jeremiah I'm leaving I'm about to walk
out scot-free we had a great time go to
another spot everything's gonna be great
Laugh Factory and Emily at the store
goes hey do you want to a spot in the
main room Joey's on it burrs on it Greg
Fitzsimmons on it I was like hell yeah
of course and we're walking through the
main room and she goes yeah you know
it's um it's like it's a benefit for
people on the spectrum and I'm like hold
on it's [ __ ] people here like once
ago cuz I just don't I was like I'll
just pass I don't know exactly how to do
it you know and then she was no no no
it's like people in a halfway house to
me halfway house is you were you know
had some drugs you maybe we're in jail
locked up and they're trying to bring
back a person I usually say drop my I go
to drug addict we're drug every doesn't
matter right no way so I go halfway
that's okay I'm walking in the back to
some guys with like beards like face
tattoos oh my god these some rough guys
are trying to get the life back together
and I'm excited because I'm like these
guys aren't gonna be offended
[ __ ] I can [ __ ] go in [ __ ] yeah I get
brought up onstage I do a couple jokes
things are going really well and then I
go into this bit this [ __ ] bin right
and you see how like wine is now yeah
multiply why it is now by like a
thousand that's what that full room felt
like really it got real quiet I'm like
this is weird but you were crushing
before that because I saw you early on
it was good I'm not I'm not the guy who
like says or killed every said like I'm
the most critical like that off it was
going it was no well yeah it was going
hard took a little turn and then I would
say I got it back up to about like 50%
right that's a hard hole to dig out of
it we were artists we were deep south
shows I walk offstage and Diaz goes uh
he goes yes yes hey uh what why'd you
closer to [ __ ] joke it's a benefit for
retouch is for [ __ ] [ __ ] it's okay
kid don't worry buddy dude balls man to
do that [ __ ] joke I thought went
pretty well bro I go back as a smaller
part rank don't know it was or just
staring at you some people were there
just to see burr you all right yeah I
don't know what the [ __ ] is they just
see bill boots so I think all those
people like ah this is awesome and then
all these people that are taking care of
a [ __ ] at home are like what the [ __ ]
is going on like I'm supported sued the
first comic that went on I think was
like mentally challenged but I didn't
know I thought he was just a comic cuz
you know comics are off job do I have a
registry
no I don't know wait a minute you know
comics can be awkward a little big-ass
yes yes yes I just thought he was
awkward and I think I came to talk about
our interaction but uh I felt so [ __ ]
bad yeah I felt so far you went to the
laughs factor after that I went to a
laugh after that yeah honestly the
audience was more [ __ ] I couldn't
believe those chosen one night due to
the more that was expected that one you
know was come another walked in Jose
okay close eyes here I saw the arm canes
out front I know it's so specific I
don't know ever retarder was just
everything who is the thing was all the
things yeah now it's just taking on a
different kind of power right oh my god
dude your shoes are [ __ ] yeah it was
just like a and if they were they were
it's like you never know when you went
home you're like oh in front of everyone
we're like shut the [ __ ] up no they're
not here and you get home like dude
honestly getting picked on for your
clothes when you were young riddled you
worse than anything else in the world
it's no matter what they can make fun of
you about if you got cheated on in front
of your friends by something you warmed
up it really did you keep it on the food
day yeah you
got some first period before school
you're like what the [ __ ] we're just
picking it out he turned it inside out
those job when I was a kid those jack is
another starter jacket yeah I wore that
and I didn't my brothers tell me hope I
had older brother you still me oh cool
they were as a Dallas Cowboy star jacket
school everyone's around me like dang
because there's like a low-income like
school so yeah white boy is a star
Jackie damn what I like dang that's a
starter jacket I went it is my first one
it is my dude I got roasted for the
entire day like you ever worry again no
no aunt no yeah we just it was like yeah
cuz I didn't know what starter was wait
you not wear starter you can but I just
didn't I well the [ __ ] thought they
were saying starter your first Jam is
your first and I went yes my first one
you're performing for that was shocking
that Dogma or no jacket baby I did have
that Charlotte Hornets one bro I knew it
dude and this was really smart and
junior high is actually what you have to
do it he in his backpack would bring a
change of clothes just in case he got
[ __ ] on on stuff that he wore I'm not
kidding he'd bring different shirts or
different like different shirts or
different like smart yeah cuz he was
always so worried yeah I don't know what
he's doing but he was so worried about
people [ __ ] on him he would bring a
change of clothes and his mom I don't
yet friends like this his mom didn't let
him wear certain she was like you're not
wearing that out of you know like no she
just didn't she just restricted him from
getting certain kinds of clothes so he
would go up by him you know secretly
stuff him in his backpack and then
change a clothes change at school so his
mom never knew he didn't want she didn't
let him wear certain stuff like if it
was like a Tupac shirt she's like where
did you get that from she would like
lose it if she saw him some [ __ ] like
that it was it was like black guys or
was it no just she's like she's like rap
you know rap culture was I got that
arrow when we were kids it was like our
parents were so against there's so many
parents against that like that could
that rise cuz it was it was so dominant
you don't I mean like yeah what hip-hop
did in the night it changed culture
forever yeah before that do you remember
your first hip-hop CD
I remember my first hip-hop tape go yeah
it was bow down Westside Connection that
was my first that was my I play I played
that tape so [ __ ] much about at you
know that song was my cassette my father
took it away because I had the n-word in
it oh wow yeah just one though I think
he heard the first the first one yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my I mean my
parents heard all my [ __ ] at some
point my dad was just like just don't
play that [ __ ] in the house those adult
covered to do amazing cover never do
that cover today which cartoon right it
was a cartoon cartoon they were it was
like yeah it was like a dog that [ __ ]
out though what's that connection I know
actual songs it was no they don't even
remember the song bow down cuz I inhaled
like you bow down sometimes that's
greater than you will know stuff Chuck
we're we're all still sported up dude it
was far grasses out the dog has a little
dog yeah you know what's great about
this era of hip-hop
you could you could use the same loop on
different songs or even three different
artists use the same the same loop of
the same sample no one gave a [ __ ] who
shared the sample doing a bunch of these
guys would share different different
loops or different samples that would
get pushed across albums of all his
whole crew really G and him would use
the same [ __ ] cuz they were cousins huh
yeah they got put they all would make
mixtapes of [ __ ] before these albums
came out I'm seeing all the same [ __ ]
that's how they got famous if you go
down to that famous record shop that he
that he shot at in Long Beach that's
that I think is still there like that um
I'm gonna signal there I don't know man
I've been on a long beach I hear record
shop you thing no bro but it's famous
what's from a music video you know that
right what's it there there you go there
you go yeah see IP records I don't think
that's even there anymore but when I
first moved to LA was still there they
still sell all their oh they used to
sell all their old mixtapes there you go
yet all those old mixtapes from all
those West Coast pearl see if there's
you want to see look at that right there
look at all these pictures all these
[ __ ] they want to see a wild
cover go to the original Guns and Roses
Appetite for Destruction cover a bunch
of [ __ ] dude it's one girls clearly
got sexually assaulted look at that dude
that's rock dude look at look at look at
the ovaries to uncover the original
let's see now they had to remake it it
was like alright this one it's the girl
she's like hanging out
that's one right there whoa I've never
seen that before dude panties around the
knees when mom bought me this CD
oh hey knees around the knees it's like
a skeleton a so elegant person who's
like just about to holy he's giving her
like a cocktail oh wow is that [ __ ] that
is she's got her titty out it looks like
she's got those like black and white
schoolgirl shoes like a schoolgirl skirt
you know yeah and he's got his pants or
anything he's got a nice sport coat on
looks like you try to bring her flowers
sorry sorry for the rape here's some
flowers what's wrong with his head is it
exploding is it a robot I keep looking
up at the at the monster coming
oh no that's a robot not a skeleton his
legs are like robots yeah I mean whoa
those two seem like they don't exist
that like they're yeah I don't matter
well I had Lord at red I choked peppers
Mother's Milk I had Mother's Milk you
remember that Mother's Milk the click
click in red over his mother's milk my
mom was livid that chief saw this cuz
this one back when album art was so dope
look at Mother's Milk to cover this red
Chili Peppers album yeah looky there all
sucking her tits right on the cover
dude I'm gonna I'm gonna jump all this
oh well coder look at how great that was
my mom was like what is this [ __ ] or no
that was porn owner I'm gonna cover I
had it with Mercedes I said jack off to
it all the time
Mercedes Nolan let's see it I love that
[ __ ] back off to this all it was my
number one source of Jack material it's
a cure they switch why I love black
girls now right over the door
yeah boy Jack did the girl the girl
looks fat as [ __ ] now back on it no her
face isn't off like oh dude why did she
pick that bloated picture she had a
tough night I don't know if you got the
photo shoot you got to do the photo
shoot but yeah all right this is
interesting
yeah you know you know when I first
started jacking onto that sex scene and
Jerry Maguire within like the first five
minutes I would loop that VHS when you
girlfriend I love remember first coming
yes I remember the whole time I came IFC
did you taste it to make sure it wasn't
he
[Music]
I love schultz minaj more dude that's
changed when I was a kid with Hastings I
found out about it
jerkin off mm-hmm and I would call in
the shower I wouldn't come because I
didn't even know what it was and then I
would just pee afterwards
and then I would I would put my finger
in the pee stream and then I taste it
and I bagged a snot come and I figured I
figured eventually one of these times it
would just taste different and that was
gonna be I'm a man now wait a minute you
would jerk off and not come I would just
jerk off like maybe like 5 or 10 strokes
could I and that stop and then I just me
hmm and I was like maybe we'll become
one of these times I didn't even
understand the whole concept of Borg I'm
not I'm not hating because it's weird
when you first start coming it's weird
you don't even know to come you don't
remember you don't remember dude not
only do I remember we don't remember the
first time I saw sex I remember no I
don't really I remember so vividly and
Ives I think I told her you got told
this on here do you remember to show I
can I remember coming and I remember
playing sure and you remember yeah you
remember - [ __ ] listen you know what
that is bro that's see no no that's yeah
that is that molestation dog you you had
some trauma you let some sexual trauma
you might have come early and tried to
black it out right dude how awesome was
because you were probably a big kid
hutch dude never lie have a babysitter
no no you had an older brother older
brother he always watched you don't have
a babysitter never lucky you got it the
older brother do you think that's why
the older brother no you just stop doing
that don't do this shop Bobby Lee said
he got molested by someone with down
since he didn't that's a funny story
so that station you heard the story he
said to me where are the podcasts he
goes he goes it's crazy because he
didn't even convince me he was like yeah
there you go right there some [ __ ] no
always have KZ on here yeah that's right
so you'll remember first time coming
down we've never been molested never
rolled
what's molested like get a pizza shop
and we're home I was maybe I maybe like
12 or something like that Allah I know
and maybe 12 so 12 13 me and there was a
girl my friends older sister would
recognize when I got boners and she
would sit on my lap and she could feel
my dick rob us if she ha got molestation
appropriate good time I loved it how old
are you 12
how old is she 17 18 [ __ ] Freddie
victimhood what I'm saying is is that
considered that I don't never know
no more traumatized by I'm truly loved
Irma I like toast I couldn't wait to go
to work
it was the whole reason I went to the
it's an ass that's what I wanted it was
my friend's sister Ariana she would just
sit on your lap dude it was a stool and
I would send this tool and then she was
like I'm tired can I share this tool
with you and I was like yeah then I
would just rock up and I and then she
would lean back up against it and it was
[ __ ] you would get hard when she sat on
your lap but before Lynch who set the
dick up and we'll shut it off settle it
said it I thought you took off the pants
let it cook it up I'll cut up the branch
you can see it through the shirt
flood flood dude IIIi mercy I would talk
up I don't think it is no that's not in
the yeah I don't think it is I don't I
don't make the argument all do get
touched
Cindy no dude no not even remotely I
don't know I didn't get it good enough
why because we have like a good
household and they'll tell on you oh I'm
a snitch
you would have snitched if you were a
kid they got touched oh yeah by a guy
yeah but by a girl you wouldn't know if
you wouldn't have said [ __ ] not done
what you did
yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't be oh you
would never have seen really molested
yes not that I know of yes yes yes you
yes he was they saw you don't think so
yeah hey I like you don't think that's
the thing is people try to block that
[ __ ] out any issues hell no no your
cutest [ __ ] emotions thing no no it's an
interesting point because I was talking
about her as a little kid what is she
cute he just had a baby chill it's a
male the feds are gonna come get you
brother gonna take your kid on let's say
know what a molester I would say love it
she's a cute kid back yeah okay sure
would all that [ __ ] you might have to
chill but there is also a point where
it's like cuz that's when I was on an
obvious thing kalila was like I was
molested whatever like that she was she
said it she was like she was like dang
or something while she was sleeping and
as horrible as that obviously is like
that's a good talent scout because you
know earlier she though she was like
nine there's no way you could see what a
how old was the say what how old was the
person I did it I didn't even get that I
should actually take another
nine-year-old it's like you know if I'm
molested no well that's shooting a shot
if it's kids if it's you
it's two kids it's fine it's weird if
it's older this is this do that you know
what this proves look at this there's
another teacher a bunch of teachers
aides got busted again blowing kids at
in the part where were these years and
today the news came out right teachers
aides arrested for sexual misconduct you
look this up who's [ __ ] more kids
teachers are priests I tweet about this
priests all day
look at this girl e----e george
teacher's aide buster for having sex
with two students in a community pool
bro
yeah that's pretty one that's great
[ __ ] picture looks like she [ __ ]
kids in floss yeah
do these kids ran a train on the T 200
that happens all the time you know this
by the way you can look up football team
[ __ ] teachers and [ __ ] that these these
teachers they see young looting kids you
have you look at Google teacher [ __ ]
football team dude here's the thing way
more she were a god kids I sorta got no
way I look up the I bet you it's I bet
you it's ten thousand on one that we
know because the priest we never hear
about this is a features aren't as good
teachers versus priests teachers versus
priests who rapes more yeses versus I
think it's teachers not rape I because
we teachers two teachers two males and
we don't care about male that's right
you get it just gets blown over it's
blown over you feel sorry for the kids
who ran a train on their history teacher
no no no not so if those kids are like
1516 I've seen some beefy 1516 year old
she was 9 a bit you were cute
I've seen some beefy 14 Houston school a
hundred times worse than what a hundred
times worse than what click on then do
we shut down schools now dude you can
find anything
confirmation bias what are you talking
about this this is diddle that's gone
I've site haha dad got diddle dotnet
will tell you everything you didn't need
to know what it's a educator sexual
misconduct
he's hold off study what up honey most
accurate data available at this time
indicates that nearly nine point six 10
percent percent of students are
that's a shitload 10% shitload of people
do all the kids ten percent of kids get
diddled by teachers that's a fuckload
but do we care know about yeah we know
know about yeah so how many right this
how many students how many how many
students are there in the United States
on average like just how many kids are
in school on average watch this
this numbers gonna blow your talking
about we're talking about K through 12
doesn't matter but just yeah yeah yeah K
through 12 how many how many K through
12 students in United States fifty
[ __ ] million five million kids get in
touch that's job you the greatest
country in the [ __ ] world u.s. survey
Stars and Bars where you at china closet
poor kids to one-child policy they got
no molesting that dude tell me i've mill
i note that we know about get touch dude
that's crazy so these kids a little
[ __ ] asses they need to complain
sympathy about it alright take that
molestation you [ __ ] roll with it
that's insane fifty fifty million so
five million kids are getting touched
that they they went home or they got
caught usually what happens the teacher
gets closer yeah teacher it on her text
blows her up every time or they found
her phone
snitches on him no the mom finds the
text and she tells the mom yeah almost
never did all those stories that I read
like the teacher's aide one his or he
got she got popped by another
administrator to someone else saw her
texting the [ __ ] hater so here's the
thing I don't understand when women do
it to a kit you're saying to say kale
stew and women molest hmm you're not
gonna come right as like there's no way
boy no the woman oh yes she's not gonna
she's not gonna come it's axe but in one
way it's actually worse right because
it's like you're doing this only for the
manipulation and abuse power or they get
the rocks off after they go home or
they're in their office and then figure
them so you can look this is a fact to
most if not all rapists like a male
rapist they don't come either no it's
extremely uncommon after yes the
physical abuse and control is what
rapists is compacted this right yeah
jerk off in the [ __ ] alley just ya
standing over where it happened there's
a lot of road sites going on right now
look at that common believes all right
rapes no rapist don't actually
because they've because of this struggle
the abuse they love the power dynamic
there's a bunch of different parts about
it like I guess I guess when I say that
I mean strangers if you're if you're
attacking someone when it's raping a
family and all that stuff all that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] away oh I don't know I don't
know yet I'm figure out who got molested
and no one did the only person that got
close was you but sound like a good time
Josh I didn't really end out his store
only fine
yeah I don't think I did honestly I got
huh you grew up in America no I was born
in Korea you were born in Korea when I
came here when I was like three okay
okay hey boy come here Jim what do y'all
want to show you something but when he
sits something on your chin
yeah you ever see oil come out of one of
these things okay you don't got this in
Korea do you chin huh he cool real Korea
we do a little differently down here
chinny chin chin you gonna take one on
your chinny chin chin No
yes sir bend over chin had to help him
help me put on my boots Jim put on my
boots chin chin goes home he make me put
on his parents luck what do you make you
do he showed me his oil stick what he's
all your stick what did he make you do
chin he making me taste his oil
I believe chin was a you know why
because I don't want to go to the harlot
talking to chant khmer khmer chen i'm
gonna show you some let me take you
around town you hungry boy you like
pancakes oh yeah I reckon cable syrup
down here for what time was it that was
it no this is it this is the beginning
of the end by the way I saw that article
they threw Shane Gillis and a canceled
culture article with like rapist oh
great it was the most fun like Harvey
mean Shane Gillis it was like I see kids
on that's the best thing for him
can you can you bring that up there's
like just to cancel culture Tim do more
time by that it's weird people go this
is actually better for us no no meaning
that being in the article is the best
thing for me very sweet
yeah you did be as exposes how how
little and insignificant his thing is
compared to those guys well well who was
it you say our new Republican is
everyone put together at them yeah who
wrote it
maybe that's it you can't so culture con
he they put his picture next to three
victims Dave Chappelle now go back I
don't know I don't know who wrote that
are do you remember who wrote it but he
but he retweeted cuz he thought it was
funny cuz he was like I go to his
Twitter handle his chin okay hold on but
they literally like grouped him it was
[ __ ] this maybe it was and they put
as ease louis c.k Shane Gillis that's
your boy Judd Apatow speaks out what is
it when did that come out go down what
is it what's the date on number six
Judd Apatow's I think is defending louis
c.k in this one I don't I'm pretty sure
oh he's not I want to read it then let's
see what he [ __ ] said I'm pretty sure
he's saying like it's ridiculous they
recorded his set what he was just on Jim
Norton he was going back and forth to do
with Jim not just
when that happened saying that while I
think he's changes to no he did I do to
God what does he say he's on the fence
thinking about the CK's resent stand up
I understand from both sides so my heart
is just a little broken about the that
have this hacky unfunny shallow routine
is just a symptom of how people are
afraid to feel everything know there's
old about about the silence in the
matter being called the white what comic
[ __ ] comic who is gayer than Isis Oh
Gilda sadly unfunny shell or tune is
just this is him talking about Lucy Kay
yeah yeah nods old news that's all
that's all news I'm Tony he did a newer
one right some kind of videos November
that was a month not even a month [ __ ]
yes
that's armor six that was new news so I
guess he hasn't change this to know that
that that's an old I don't know whatever
it is whatever its Santino and one of
the weirdest things value is how much
you love judge stand-up Santino will DME
clips from Judd stand up he'll like
watch he'll like somehow he'll like
screen grab the videos from which I've
never seen dude then I don't know I'm
like look program are using a screen
grab as I spend crazy go buy it from yet
you told me i screen grab and I send it
over and he'll soon and he'll be like
dude I'm [ __ ] be like rolling on the
floor I'll say ROFL brothel pumpkin
calves like Rafa and Carolyn on the
floor dude died and laughing he'll send
me this video of like him throwing the
strike
did you see the Mets King yeah when you
threw that perfect to remember way
through the perfect strike to the first
baseman to pick off the guy stealing it
was insane it was it was probably a
heater maybe it was I think they clocked
it at like 96 I'm not even be something
like he tells run first pitch to pitch
rows for each other
dude I'm not kidding Santino literally
goes my president he writes that as the
captions yes video hi hi president look
at this look at this this is worse his
are 57 any worse this is hot this is hot
skin heat dude what are you talking
about Santino has those sorts I same
same same shorts same Jersey
I bought a Patel Mets Jersey just
because I wanted to have
or watch this heat much as hot huh all
right
would you talk about this is flame hey
what's up ready shake it off baby take
the cue all right a burner damn dude
I can't believe no one's picked him up
see I fire yeah fire get out of that
it's just not a just uh Nath Lee you
know pure I think pure ethically puree
its way everybody [ __ ] to everyone
[ __ ] up when they do these two you see
how many people go and do that and
you're like if you couldn't throw a
baseball why was it great but also
practice before that doesn't matter if
you don't throw baseballs don't say yes
don't say yes yeah that's fair don't say
yeah if they did an inaugural first kick
at a football game and I don't I don't
know how to kick well yeah I would never
say yes agree yeah I go know what the
funny to embarrass you in front of
America now know what the [ __ ] you
talking about like did you see the thing
they're doing now we're in the college
ball games at halftime if the kids are
there compete for their college to it
dr. pepper thing to the thing but then
you're going like this there did they
throw it like this the girls the girls
lit up this dude but you she beat the
[ __ ] out of what is this you have to
throw a football through a dr. pepper
can on the field have fun show now okay
if you whoever wins they pay for your
college tuition okay but the thing on
how far it is yeah there's my girl
version feet away yeah and the the and
but they're not throwing it like a
football they're grabbing and like two
hands he's like sitting it on your hand
she's under handing it through the thing
and she's lighting this dude up I don't
know if this is the one this is it cuz
they do them all the time I do a bunch
of them has eight million views on this
one she gets she got 100k well the one I
was watching the dude was look at this
yeah oh that's ten yards or five yards
it's five years five years it's noisy
fifteen feet look at her beep little
[ __ ] buckets buckets oh this is that up
look at her mano a dude
no it's not these are 200 grand she gets
for Twitter sockets pockets pockets
kid look at this kid unless the joke's
on you I got a full ride to Notre Dame
he's throwing a couple in there though
boom she's like what she's like one of
those Asian guys at the Papa Schadt you
ever seen those videos those Asian guys
into two at once channa are you relating
the shots
Papa Schadt oh it's an Asian woman that
can do two at once all yeah
yes halftime shows now dude you don't
you don't watch college football no you
don't watch any sports no I love sports
he loves a basket not I love basketball
boxing and I'm getting into MMA a little
bit because it is II know I just I like
the theatrics of it now and I feel like
I feel like there's a elite athlete
entering the sport it feels MMA
interesting you don't think there has
been I think they've been and they've
been I don't think Ali this is your
category I know nothing about this [ __ ]
what do you guys not not that not that I
just had Dominic raised on the food
truck diary yeah and he was a football
player and actually got a shot in the
NFL with the Jets and the Giants yeah
and I said he explained to people like
when they go this guy's a good athlete
where the time I George st. Pierre and
silver when they are always a good
athlete about the athletes that were in
just your locker room like it's I mean
compared a bookies and he's fighting
he's fighting John Jones yeah and I said
here for so just so people can
understand there's dem stream being a
good fight or being an athlete I said if
before you and John fight if you did a
combine you had a forty vertical did the
agility did all that stuff did the 20
yard - everything yeah you would
absolutely destroy John Jones destroy
him a flea was yeah right every day he'd
blown out the water different technical
skills that people have to practicing it
those are athletic they know but not a
very I don't know every great athlete
can just walk into a combine and
merderet know this is what he's saying
my training thing no no no no this is
the run it's phat run fast jump high
what are the things it's like it's
change of direction explosiveness those
things are just green in you yeah you're
gonna you have to train for the jump
I agree but like John Jones vertical is
gonna be I don't know like 28 yeah if
the I know I agree but I'm just saying
those aren't grain but the way that you
see these guys when they train for the
combine it's very specific to the
combine they they're they do better
technique with the four yards there's a
lot of technique guys are just like
organically or super athletic I think
that's what yeah I agree some of those
guys enter some of those guys enter like
boxing or MMA
right Kranz they have an advantage and
even you you said this about yourself
you an advantage at a lower level
against these guys just because you were
more athletic than them even then they
have you had a huge advance huge of it
and then you start going to like the top
of the top then you get experience yeah
I think and when you're dealing with
someone who's been doing something since
they're six years old like that Andy
Ruiz fight I can't believe that he came
and so [ __ ] heavy but like
unbelievable by the way it was this
whole thing but it was like himself
think about it he was key came at 283
and he fought the whole fight at the
same pace that's what he had to what he
had but think about it he's been boxing
six years old doing 12 rounds is nothing
yeah
no it's nothing using cruise control
there's a fight the entire of the
paycheck didn't wanna get knocked that's
it let's wait III came in there sweetie
there he's impressive than me though
mumbly it's so impressive that you can
just cruise like that and just knocked
out I'm blows my mind like that to me
incredibly didn't mind that fight oh I
wish Josh would have knocked them out
but no I thought Joshua father smart
fight but don't you think that's a such
a skill Ruiz like he that's just a skill
that he's exercised Ruiz yeah that's
just a skill he's lazy man you know if
it's lazy as much as that what do you
know he's lazy it was self sabotage he
gained 15 and I heard about this before
going in let him eat fat boy I need a 10
piece [ __ ] you got to come through man
that's you that is a winnable fight for
him he beat him before and it's like
your this is your one opportunity and
the only advantage you huh well what
about what about the idea that he's
setting himself up to fight again if he
won that fight he'll fight again if you
won that if you won that fight he
would've made a hundred million dollars
I was not fighting him again now he's
off it he's it's off else now you gotta
fight journeyman know your your cliche
you're the Buster Douglas you're the guy
who gotta butter me up you [ __ ] up
yeah not butter beans a little bit broad
of an example brought round here no Tony
it's Bruce super specific yeah with the
sideshow that was beside you what I'm
saying is you're gonna become a sideshow
he's a cliche guys yeah you got that guy
yeah I'd [ __ ] it up who do you have a
fight who would I have them fight you
can rematch Parker whose work doesn't
really have a name loser es Ortiz but
then like who's gonna watch them know I
guess Mexicans if there's not
don't ride with them now they're done so
if they don't ride for him he's done
he's [ __ ] he's done and he had the
opportunity but he had the frustrating
opportunity so you watch too much boxing
good I'm like grandmother in a boxing
like my dad used to cover boxing for you
when he worked in the news business oh
really
he'd been to like Ali's camp a bunch of
time to him like crazy [ __ ] and so I was
like a huge boxing fan growing up and
then MMA I'm starting to get into and
you watch everything yeah there wasn't a
sport that I don't like I'm being dead
serious last night I watch women's
handball I watch the Olympic handball
team disappointing what do you mean it
was so much fun to watch dude I don't
get any any premier athlete on petition
I will watch any premier athlete do what
they do and let me tell you something
much CrossFit I'll watch those cook the
CrossFit competitions love that [ __ ] if
you're a pretty hot WNBA hell no I don't
watch that I said premier athlete okay
let me know what that is no I watch the
Olympic Channel sometimes I throw it on
when I'm when I'm doing work in bed okay
and an Olympic channel has like all the
trial runs and it's fun to watch these
people of sports that I've never heard
of her I've never seen before right [ __ ]
is wild as [ __ ] it doesn't make sense to
me I'm more mesmerized by sports I know
nothing about because we don't feature
them in America right but this is tough
it's kind of like its water polo you put
on without the light and smoke each
other they can smack you in the face
it's super good listen first of all it's
not gay it's a bunch of girls who are
gay there's a guys look at that so I
think some of them it's kind of dope you
dive to the air instead water polo
without one you really try to justify
this bro yeah no you know what a so I'll
watch any any any athletic competition
at a high level I do want like the
Olympic Trials are great did you see the
worst tennis player in the world look
that up you'll laugh you're fogging
in the Olympics dude this is amazing so
all these countries they have to throw
in their hat in the ring cuz they just
want to see if they yeah you know and
like Rome no no poor kid they give them
the opportunity there you're trying to
build sports in these theoretical
countries that don't really have them so
it's got to be on bro it's [ __ ] up
they let these guys who have never swam
before in the swim and come to Olympic
trial these guys are [ __ ] going
against dude they're gonna get to
Michael Phelps and there's just yeah
it's just like one guy from Nigeria
shake the pool with Phelps you know doc
say what at least they shared the try to
google it just try to Google again it
just can't
there was a Michael Kosta who's a you
guys you know Kosta I know Kyle's dope
comic he tweeted about it because he was
a professional tennis player yeah and he
was like this is what it's like when
someone tells me they're their cousin
does stand yeah
he's like this is what it [ __ ] go to
Michael Kosta Twitter maybe that's the
best way to find it but when you watch
this you go this is how you you forget
how [ __ ] dope some of these people
are it's like when an average joe's like
I could [ __ ] shoot up on tennis and no
it cost him with the K sorry hmm he's so
funny
Michael Costas [ __ ] hysterical of
he's good look out his Twitter he's
still in the Daily Show yeah yeah he's
still funny he's out there go down
scroll down and there this nerd video
right there this made me laugh so hard
woody but but first the tweet said I
think he said something like this is
this is like when someone tells me they
are comic because they were Christmas
party for a house watch this [ __ ]
video watch this poor kid dude it's a
beaut it's the kid on our side of the
camera down by us zoom in on that just
this kid serving
the other guy doesn't even want to [ __ ]
with him he's like barely playing
because he said oh dude and this guy
this is the Olympian his country he's a
pro this is a professional match my
friend good for him what country is he
from dude roll down it right isn't it
says it right there the other guy's like
what the [ __ ] am i doing what a waste of
[ __ ] time
thailand's wait Ukraine bruh stylin I
mean got a couple over Jesus Christ
Kallen beat the piss out of them I just
it's just it's a tile a tile an and
whatever oh I don't know where did you
I'm sure you even Charlemagne have
discussed this and I definitely European
where'd you guys land on the Kaepernick
stuff because I'll say this when it went
when he had that tryout and went hard I
kept I don't know why I didn't look into
it that much I kept saying just want to
play self-sabotage you still wanna play
if you wanna play get the [ __ ] out gonna
be just the celebrity do that and then
we look more into it and you see the
contractor they're trying to give them I
was like oh good for him man good for
him for not doing it I think they kind
of [ __ ] him because he reasons dis
Goga before you go on the other thing
when they go oh well the he's decided to
set up a workout whatever an hour away
from where they moved it they changed it
last minute that's what happened but
here's the thing the reason he already
had that location set up is because
there's closer to the airport so people
could make it did you know that yeah
dude but go I think that's too much
distrust on both ends yes the NFL and
Collin yeah so when you have that
nothing can happen I think Collin is
rightfully concerned about the
intentions of the NFL do you think he
wants to play yes III think he lies I
don't know I think you would ruin like
what what he's become I feel like he's
almost I don't think of Charlemagne's
plan I feel like he's almost bigger than
football now ya know he is bigger than
football now III think that if you want
a job cuz at the end of the day it's a
job if you want a job
you have to be willing to acquiesce to
the demands of the job it takes a [ __ ]
says hey I need you to audition for this
job on Saturday at this place if you
want it you just do it you should do it
no brank you if you truly want right
yeah and I think the biggest problem
with this whole thing is this was never
about Collin in the NFL was about police
brutality yes now we've completely
stopped talking about police brutality
nobody even mentioned I transit police
were tell you is he though he doesn't
even talk about it
well let's say out there with Collin is
he doesn't talk at all so don't be upset
if the media is let's everyone else boys
exactly so so I think that Collin could
do a lot of things better I think his
intentions were great it's like who
doesn't want to support ending police
brutality like that's or at least being
you know aware of it or on board
addressing it but now it seems about you
getting a job at the NFL and I frankly
don't give a [ __ ] if you play football
how about how about the well nobody does
I mean I look I don't you know the
receiver that was in the video here you
got picked up yep drop in those passes
that's a big patch you just like drop in
black people's hope I think I think it
like look I don't I don't I take back a
little bit like I don't the reason I
said yes that he wants to play football
here's why I don't think he really does
wanna play in the NFL anymore but I but
you do know what you said what we talked
about is like when you grew up your
whole [ __ ] life do these kids are
machines since childhood to play these
sports and that's all they know like
like that's all you know some saying
that's all you know so when you reach
this this level there will always be a
piece of them it's why people don't quit
it's why Jordan played on the Wizards
it's like there's a piece of these guys
that always kind of want the thing a
little bit even if they don't really
want to play but definitely to go play
and see if you're a good exam he's not
gonna go play in the [ __ ] CFL because
it's a tragedy then it's like a sad Yale
well you're a good example because I
think you want that thing you want the
NFL the NBA whatever your dream is right
because it fills a void that you have
and because you had that void you were
willing to like work so hard to try to
fill it right and you got all this
attention you got all this respect and
then you find something else
you found podcasting you found standup
just and now all the sudden that fills
the void I think Colin has found
something else it's not podcast not
stand up and go and it's it's being you
know a figure four still domain
he's still the mint when he walks in the
room way more than man matter of fact
before he was a guy who you didn't
really know if he could make a throw or
not you didn't know if he could make
second breeds now he is a guy who is
really leading the charge from power
yeah dude how it's crazy to say he's
leading the charge when he doesn't speak
on the subject [ __ ] now guess what I'm
saying I think I agree has another thing
if he had nothing else agree then I
don't think then I think he would really
want to play but because he has a thing
and so many people look up to him he's
so like he's inspired so many people I
think his heart is full and I think when
your heart is full you don't need it as
much like I bet it was way easier to
quit MMA when you had all this other
[ __ ] poppin if you had nothing you still
be banging with these [ __ ]
today probably 100% so but I think what
caught the only reason why I backed up
getting I looked at all the details in
contract that the NFL did give him
there's such mistrust the contract is
base like cool you do this workout you
can't sue us for anything else moving
forward you're out you do this we gave
you your fair shot
shut the [ __ ] up he's like now hold up
that's kind of fair though it's not fair
to me I too me too
they're giving you an opportunity to
show up and he'll react all the teams
yeah one place where you hit whether you
get to audition now that sound for any
but never done it for anybody in the
history of the league we're gonna bring
the whole [ __ ] leave to you you and
if you got the soil out we don't care
what you do like this idea like the NFL
has like a morale clause it's like no
they're like kicking women shooting up
strip clubs they would have hired Aaron
Hernandez if he's such a good player in
a heartbeat they're all still [ __ ] up
no one's hiding their fuck-ups it's
still happening dude it'd be interesting
to see what happens with Antonio Brown
oh he'll get picked up the the Eagles
will pick him up I guarantee by weekend
you know the other problem really that's
whether or not he even wants to keep
this [ __ ] charade up I don't even
know if he wants to keep playing
football
no he's begging Tom Brady he does have
you not seen this ya become this [ __ ] is
so funny but hey big bro
I miss you Congrats like Emily's so
important all the time I think even he
knows that liabilities are just [ __ ]
well he knows it's a rat you know
there's a rap for him and right now he's
doing anything he possibly can I bet he
goes pick him up because because have we
heard anything the NFL's done
investigation I've heard anything about
this and the girl who did come out about
this try coming gears but
for n came after another dude so it's
like it's a little [ __ ] messy what is
she saying that he beat her up uh that
rehear aped her was but they had we late
but they had a relationship before I
thought it was a physical death oh wow
no late yeah but I guess she has kind of
a dodgy pass so but the NFL looked into
it have you heard anything
well the Sports Center was talking about
it there that Tony comes out he said
he's still topped three four receivers
in the league yeah so there are Eagles
would sign that I think the Eagles gonna
sign that's what I think happens to the
player I don't know patron eat them to
me yeah yeah they do yeah they
absolutely do but that they're
definitely not as much as much of the
NFL i ball is on the Patriots there's no
way they're picking him up so II thought
they don't need more attention on those
guys oh that's all they do they've had
problems for so long now of everyone
sniffing at them constantly it's like
you that you don't to call more
attention here's the thing is every
we're to fly under the radar those
[ __ ] everyone else would point
those fingers be like leave us alone
leave us alone we're doing our work
we're doing our work you know I mean
that's kind of been his program ever
since they started investigating you
know [ __ ] deflategate and all that
stuff all they did was cause more
attention than more attention more so
now I think they just need to fly super
low so did you hear out of them did you
hear what happened last week with the
the cats a photographer called him again
right yeah you hear what he asked he was
can you guys just believe everything off
my camera pretend this never happened
then it feels like no dumbass yeah my
keepers pretending he has credentials as
a photographer he's taking pictures the
other team film the other teams coaches
yeah but you know what they've been
cheating all along yeah but - but every
but all a lot of teams cheat though
model no yes they you think that she's
like the Astros here's the deal we don't
say that what's gonna happen with that
with the arrows [ __ ] do you think
they're gonna take away the chip no I
think they do no way I think they're
dealing other team signals and playbooks
has been since the beginning of time
that's something not to this degree and
especially when a coach comfort more
they look at it like mad Patricia dude
especially when you work under somebody
like Val check you think you're not
gonna take that influence somewhere else
and just you know just because you're
not copying what they're doing or you're
not [ __ ] you shall have the influence
in you this here's the thing a lot of
the Astros at home when they were
filming to the Astros won on the road
without it great zero a dog [ __ ] on
wrote at home the boys were wallet with
the cheats their ball the bottom line is
with a sport like baseball you got a
[ __ ] you you have to you have to be
able to play good often to still win a
game right
you can't win on defense in a baseball
game it doesn't happen you can win on
defense at a football game your defense
can score defense can't score in base
you know what they were doing right I'm
just saying you can't afford baseball in
defense I know dart doesn't exist
feeling the signs and they knew what
balls were coming so what you should hit
that sighs yeah but still if I notice of
curve ball and I'll see the staff show
that is look this up you can find out
how many of these batters they can read
these pictures what they're throwing
half the time themselves because they
face these guys so on I'm just don't you
look at this advantage though you have
to admit it's an advantage than all of
you in American sports is try to find
advantages right and there's new ones
and illegal ones I'm fine with all of
them [ __ ] it let them do apps takes line
with them makes a game most interesting
yes it's a [ __ ] at the end of the day
it's not the USA it's not like if we
lose one of these games that's why I got
mad at the hole true and the Kapernick
thing then put it on the troops the
[ __ ] troops have nothing to do with
the black guys playing a sport for fun
so we can watch it on Sunday this is
entertainment it's specifically for us
to get our rocks off they have something
to do it means nothing to the
progression of this country this old
idea that like we're this morally
upholding country where the most
backwards-ass [ __ ] lying [ __ ]
hypocritical system on earth but because
we want our sports to be clean and prim
and proper it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
silliness yeah but they're all it
whereas whereas impair as imperfect as
the people that we pay to watch but
whether they're closed systems is
perfect according to what you said no
system would you rather it's not what
system I'm saying we should stop
pretending they're know we're not
perfect what I'm saying is like who else
should in that arch who does it better
like can we look to and go man we really
got to be normal like Sweden North Korea
Oh buddy but I think we should be less
hard on ourselves about [ __ ] like that
then you know with cheaters and stuff oh
that's oh yes with all that style it
takes cheaters holitzer not enter sports
they should they these two things should
be separate anyway yeah but you have to
live with the illusion
of freedom in the illusion of democracy
or the whole thing falls through sports
through everything I think she their
passports is where we check out it's
like it was stand-up we do we get when
we get what is about sports right what
is the one thing about sport right is
that at the end of the day there's not
some like government body that's gonna
give you an advantage it's your running
ability versus my running a bill it's
the one thing in life that we get to go
to we go at least this is fair there's a
yes like my life isn't fair because and
you know it's not got it I know what
you're saying and it [ __ ] breaks your
heart when you find out it's not fair
you hold on this guy's stealing signs
the one place where I get to tune in the
rest of my life I'm [ __ ]
you know the one place where it gets
tuned in at least this is fair and it's
not you're like oh okay here's what
you're saying remember Hollywood when
you start to understand how Hollywood
really worked yeah it's the saddest
thing on earth hi Luke your heart right
yes you're like wait a minute I'm funny
I'm gonna go in this audition I'm gonna
win it because I'm funny and then you
start realizing they're like oh no they
just don't want to read it yeah anyway
what the [ __ ] is that you know but I'll
show you this is almost my point nothing
is fair so in that turn I'm kind of like
I'm okay with the idea that things are
the way they are we could all talk by
the way from the people that's the
things like pull back because do you
when you did you assume everybody was
clean and on PD's yes interesting and
like I think that assumption I think
that assumption is good like okay
so naturally the the three of us and a
lot of people listening to this podcast
right if you're into comedy at all we're
all comedians we're all just [ __ ]
conspiracy theorists but like we're
funny mmm right we're just like how do I
think of another way around this right
that's all conspiracy yeah and the same
thing so when we're watching sports were
like ooh but what if we're thinking
about but what if with everything right
yeah I think the average person isn't
and that's why they're so upset when
they find out and I think they need it I
think on some level they need it and
they want to believe like hey I can be a
billionaire someday and hey I could hey
my business can be totally fine and then
you know the government's not gonna come
in is the American dream that but
without the American dream everything
crumbles [ __ ] even if you don't have it
the fact that people get to go to work
every day going now I might win the
lottery this week that gets them in next
week yeah it's chaos we get out it I
agree that's a good that's a good thing
to have
but but as an adult when you grow up yes
you learn the unfairness of the world
and you just deal with it like a
grown-up and go that is what it is this
is a part of the system
yo is what it is he clean is crucial
yeah is what it is is so crucial and
it's so important because it basically
is adulthood yeah right adulthood is
what it is is what it is it's not it's
not just it is what it is people [ __ ]
need a lie they do they need look we're
an election season you're gonna hear
some lies your cousin is is saying
they're gonna give everybody a thousand
not no one's getting a thousand dollars
who's his buddy who's your country yang
is Andrew yang I mean I did first or
second so no sir said Wayne is appointed
no one's getting everything that they're
saying that they're gonna call [ __ ]
Bernie's not giving you health care no
it's a [ __ ] dream no Bernie might be
the only one who actually believes he's
gonna do it everybody else not liable I
believe he's gonna probably I gotta say
you guys did you see the [ __ ] Trump
the most recent rally I don't care how
you feel about Trump the guy's funniest
[ __ ] hilarious cannot deny I said
that I said when drawing own little
rocket man was the funny thing I've ever
heard in my life so they play the Trump
thing let's see bro look at this I reap
Oh stood it all you did holy [ __ ] this
thing it's on my Twitter he's so
ridiculous it's it this had me [ __ ]
howling last night I woke them up
I woke mark and Alex up in the Airbnb
just to watch this video go down go down
go down this one right here yes go to
the beginning go to the grenade he's
talking about Elizabeth Warren remember
when she had that video you see her beer
deal where she said oh darling I've seen
that too darling it's about her husband
darling it's great to see you what are
you doing here it's like that's her
husband's supposed to be living in the
house turn this over
[Music]
[Applause]
can I get a beer let's get up here you
know she wants to be one of the group
hey let's get a beer did you ever see
such a phony disgusting he was hard in
the paint man bro
he called Buddha Judge Alfred Newman
hilarious hilarious Mad Magazine guy
that impeachment stuff just feels like
it's like such a waste of time and
that's why he's doing this that's what
he keeps up this because this is
offensive his superpowers you say oh
yeah I go on the offensive yeah the
thing about him is that he never is a
and it's actually a brilliant strategy
I never realized it but like he never
defends himself no no he just attacks
and the brilliant thing about it is no
blacks nothing just people who listen
anybody listen to politics State they've
hacked like [ __ ] children like we're
discussing politics without putting our
personal opinion on politics we're just
talking Brian Collins not here to
destroy this podcast with yeah he well
he ruins almost every one of these shows
by the way a million times I just was
the show but you know so it's like what
he does is an interesting strategy right
somebody says something about him yeah
he's been in pseudo politics but also
entertained in ten years he knows like
you said earlier everybody's a phony
piece of [ __ ] yeah so when she when the
Biden say the Ukraine thing with him
he's like are you talking about me he's
gonna go hard so and all these people
got dirt I was I forget exactly who said
it but politics is a mudslinging contest
right but he's made a mud yeah everybody
else wearing white he's made of mud you
know what's brilliant he does the exact
same thing that like we've talked about
this before about he does the same thing
that clever people in comedy or
entertainment to when somebody attacks
us instead of us attacking them I let my
fans go after them so I just walk away
so what he does what's smart is when
someone goes Trump XYZ he doesn't
comment on it his [ __ ] fan base they
do all the Fox News does all of his work
for him he didn't even ask him to do
yeah they just go do it it's weird it's
like when somebody says Andrew Schultz
sucks if you just retweet that watch
what happens to that guy from your fans
your fans you don't need to do a need
them yeah you don't need it so he's
everything and every tweet because I
don't want them to think I saw it I just
mean you know what I mean give the power
to the people
Trump smart enough to just go watch this
watch what [ __ ] hillside react oh
yeah he does he'll stop what he does
enable yes
he picks how powerful they are exactly
if you have no power
he's not talking about na unless he can
use what you said to leverage right
right so like it's just interesting
whoever bubbles up is like somebody
who's uh who's like a pretty good front
runner etc he'll start to take shots at
something goes on one effort and then
these people these like politicians most
these politicians are coddled they're
not like [ __ ] real men you know what
I mean they're like they're guys who
have like rich [ __ ] dads and that
kind of [ __ ] they never had ball no one
wrote that um she's [ __ ] life he got
into Yale probably because of some
nepotism [ __ ] and then also you're on
stage and this Google idea with the
footlight yeah destroying orange fades
or white on the [ __ ] downs roasting
the [ __ ] do you do yeah and if they just
crumble whoever but like wait when
you're in the line of fire what someone
who knows how to roast it's over
it gets unless you got it it's over you
see we've seen you see it firsthand it's
ugly as [ __ ] when he does the Democratic
when he [ __ ] I can't wait I can't wait
well he like lines up the Democrats it's
all firing squad myself man dude I can't
wait I want it but here's the thing is
he I think he just I think we all know
what he knows is that he didn't [ __ ]
he didn't want to be President he was
surprised that he won president he just
wanted to be able to talk [ __ ] and run
all the way up the flagpole and when he
got up there he was like I'm the best
that solidified him being like I am best
I are you go he's gotta have an ego
right now but now it's final T I think
he thought I do for using in the [ __ ]
out Banaszak
oh you don't think I can do it channel D
he wants to do it yeah if I went oh no
you stay man he might god [ __ ] I'm
out but now I've only ghost dude you're
the worst president ever he's like oh
really I'm gonna be miserable I'm stay
another for watch he's gonna make he's
gonna he's gonna make some law where he
can go three terms it'll just sit the
[ __ ] up the sick dude he did that I'll
bring it that's on the tweak he said
that he goes he goes 20 20 20 24 2028
he goes I'm just kidding these stupid
people MSNBC they they're gonna act like
it's real I'm just kidding maybe I'm not
though maybe we go for it
funny it's such a good man but you can't
even admit he's funny cuz in these
[ __ ] idiots start cold oh you agree
with every one of his policies this I
know I don't know agree with every comic
but I can say they're funny yeah there's
a lot of comics that are hilarious it's
just the ID idea now as people are
afraid to be even associated with them
because they think that you're you you
are backing up what he sees radioactive
so if you say anything good about a
radioactive substance you must be
radioactive people right and then what
they just make you radioactive yeah
nobody wants to talk so when we say this
by the way we're referring to an
extremely small percent of the
population the more they talk to the
more people I taught when you drop a
social media yes the more people you
talk to in this [ __ ] country they
have they have enough sensibility to
know that we're talking about this thing
in comedic light and they know what you
know is they're [ __ ] they joke about
the same [ __ ] that you see what this
[ __ ] there's a normal Democrat in the
middle of this country would say the
same thing they go this [ __ ] was
hilarious II this [ __ ] bozo Jeff yeah
because they're they have sensibility
but we're talking about the mind the
minority of social media that loses
their mind over nothingness right
they're very small we see them as large
because they're in our face every day
and we're in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
business but dude you go to most of the
country they get it they get it a lot
more because they deal with it
differently we were just absorbed by
Twitter we're like Fort Worth we have to
live inside of this [ __ ] this this
this echo chamber sphere of like you're
either on this side now you're on this
side and if you're one of those same
jealous of those commands who don't deal
with it there's a few community you
don't deal at all deal with why I'm a
social media that the whole social world
yeah oh you know what it is whew there's
a few not a lot even burr is on [ __ ]
Instagram now it's like some of those
guys avoided it forever and you got to
do it finally got in you kind of you
kind of have part of it it's like it's
honestly it's no different than any
sport it's like as the supportive all's
you need to learn more things like what
happened in MMA all of a sudden these
wrestlers start to come in and people
like oh [ __ ] I better learn how to gotta
get on the ground
oh yeah I do that wrestling I think it's
weird when you hear like sometimes go
I'm not gonna do the [ __ ] the
Instagram human like that's a waste of
time man like I just do it on the stage
and like not here you don't want to be a
cop or they go well the only reason he
sells take because he has a successful
comedy podcast like no I I get it dude
that's the game like you don't have all
that when everyone came of all that he
says do you don't want to be
he employs ease there immediately
followed by a jealous nonsense statement
that doesn't mean anything the only
reason that Schultz gets the only reason
that shop the only reason statements are
cop-outs for their insecurities of
jealousy of whatever that's where they
are in the in the game but the reality
of the matter is like as the game
changes you need to do what it takes to
succeed within it right and if you want
to play basketball you need to have a
trainer that comes with you all year
round yeah LeBron pays its trainer all
year round and the elite MBA players do
that this is a requirement for the new
NBA back in the day you could work
converse [ __ ] like crazy so now there's
more that you have to do maybe it's
comedy podcast maybe it's supposed
Eclipse maybe it's you know YouTube
whatever it is yeah just do the road you
need to do it yeah and if you don't want
to do it if it's not worth it to you
then you don't want to be a comic but
that's fine fine but you have to accept
that right just have to accept that's
what's part of the game right now this
is the most competitive industry in the
world because it's the best [ __ ] life
like we get to talk [ __ ] on a stage for
a living the best and talk show right
here nothing but it should be hard to do
yeah you should suffer yeah in 10 years
yeah you should get nothing
you should get beaten down you should
get weeded the [ __ ] out and the ones who
could really handle it stay in the game
sell tickets sell is that yeah and you
sell tickets yep yeah you can do it how
you can develop that fanbase and to be
honest now is the time where like back
in the day you could not have an opinion
right because you were funneled into the
Hollywood system now if you don't have
an opinion you don't have anyone know
yeah that's the thing you can't be one
foot in one foot out oh no because
there's a group for you yeah there's no
group for who is your group yeah if you
are if you're this guy's guy you better
be a guy's guy
don't be the guy's guy who wants to
appease the Nerds and want to appease
Hollywood both kill note right you got
because the other guys guys are going I
know he's got the vibe but he's trying
to pander to them a little bit so I
can't really trust him and the Nerds are
like he's too much of a bro yeah so now
you got nobody yeah so it's like you
have to make a choice now are you
willing to be hated yeah yeah stamp
something are you want to be hated yeah
yeah certain port portion of the
population that hates you a lot of them
and that equal part is gonna love you
yeah and as much as they hate you these
people love you that means you have a
career debt boom
kind of like was the irony sometimes
they tell you straight up who you are
which is even more interesting you don't
mean like you mean they culture when
they call Joe like what people call Joe
alright that nothing makes me laugh
harder like that when they when you
sometimes they try to level you into the
a group because they're afraid of of
like you they're afraid of you and
they're afraid of life into radioactive
thing right it's if I make you
radioactive I don't even have to talk to
you yeah if I call you a racist right
that's it's racist won't you sit down
with him I don't sit down with races no
I would never but he's well how do you
know he's a racist what cause he's
racist yeah here mouth you just say
there's certain things you just say like
we call someone a pedophile right you're
not letting them babysit your kids even
if it's fake even if we have this big
joke to commentary it's precautionary
we're just busting balls but like this
is a truth in my neighborhood they were
talking about doing this thing that a
sheriff a sheriff did this I don't know
where I think it was in California you
have to look it up but he was going
around planting signs in sexual
offenders front yard I love it for
Halloween [ __ ] yeah saying do not
trick-or-treat at this home whatever the
local police department was I remember
who what
but our neighborhood was like voting on
it I love it and and people actually
were against it now watch it I would put
him in the firaon they go what if the
crime wasn't as serious I go well that's
what you get when you get what you get
not my issue doesn't matter is what it
is yeah what it is don't touch kids
science on three sex offenders homes
here will cease no I love that's what he
wasn't allowed to apparently as a parent
they said no but they voted on in our
place to do it because it was like a
town council was like let's see if
enough people say yes then it's a town
thing it's mind boggling we even let
them out if you touch kids you just kill
him you're out you just killed that
you're out I'm so okay yeah you just
[ __ ] shoot them right here out that
you'll see what it's a great little
person going let's give them another
chance but touch it to say here's why
here's why
because it's so prevalent that there's
so many people that get [ __ ] up with
this thing happy that it powerful people
that they silent dude Epstein is [ __ ]
proof of how many powerful people we
thought Alex Jones yes just making it up
and then you see you're like holy
this Oracle he feed knew all these Oh
pootie said [ __ ] that everyone decide
we're cool people tonight in four years
I'm not saying I knocked off his rock no
he's off his rocker but a lot of she's
had some she throws a lot of mud and
some of it sticks and when it does stick
you're like oh he got he talked about
Thailand so much and people thought that
was a joke
that he was mocking it making up and
dude years later I I remember reading it
and going holy [ __ ] Louis Jones I'd like
to here's the ocean here's the question
about the island right so we assume
obviously this is some sort of like
they're trying to like get influence in
power positions whoever they is it
doesn't matter yeah right
but they're trying to have influence in
power positions right so that they're
they're getting these powerful people to
bang underage girls videotaping and
saying hey we got you on video being a
pedophile go for this you got to do what
we tell you Scientology it's the same
theory is that what Scientology I told
you that wraps them and all their
fuck-ups and then they tell them they
use it against and they make that they
do this thing called auditing where you
admit all your fuck-ups it's like when
you go into Catholic Church you admit to
the priests peak you did just doing 12
Hail Marys they got this [ __ ] on tape
and you do it in their little hours yeah
endless hours and so when they do is
they say if you're trying to get out of
this [ __ ] just know we had that
recording about that time that you
talked about touching that
sixteen-year-old girl but I got it know
what Tom Cruise did come on bro you're
never gonna find you're never gonna know
he's the cat he's the head guy he's the
head cattleman Travolta they run that
[ __ ] they got seek requisite
Will Smith in it for a sec you know I
don't know if he was not out apparently
they do like a new thing every year what
are we gonna say though about the okay
basically so here's my question about
the obscene thing you know that they're
trying to trap these people with
underage girls yeah how many these
people that went to the island or went
on the plane bang the girls but didn't
know they were underage so for example
look at me look at me right now yeah
they all knew they were honoring see
that's the thing
I don't know Grandal I don't agree I do
I agree and look look I'm I'm the guy
who says kill pedophiles right yeah
totally okay with that yeah hundreds
then take them out done yeah I've wonder
if these guys are on a plane and they're
seeing these girls who are maybe 16 or
some but that maybe they're made up
maybe that was kind of [ __ ] and they're
just going oh we got some young hot ass
here
it's creepy of course but maybe they're
not jumping - I have a
Eagle girls on the plane they're banging
these prostitutes because they're in the
press but how do you have you ever been
on a college campus recently I could if
you asked me how old that girl isn't oh
I have no idea yes yes but being a
conscious associate your first thought
is I wonder how old this [ __ ] can I
tell you the first thing I would tell
let's say the three of us are on this
island I'm at your it's your [ __ ] I
did an island retreat and I've seen out
of a tree you're playing catch like a
retriever
those girls come at me and you're like
god damn me like yeah dude 21
I would like okay timeout
I'd like oh she know what you're know
you know they would stay you know gold
is blackmail remember the goal is
blackmail so you're not gonna risk yeah
think about you're not gonna risk them
not being into teenagers or huh right
yeah I want them to [ __ ] them so you can
use it you'll probably say they're of a
oh there's and then arrows 30 yeah yeah
like a waitress or someone went around
with psycho man you don't leave these
girls are 22 ever I be the only cat on
the island checking IDs though that'd be
me I reckon I get can I see your ID I
just Nancy I do you have IDs on my own
okay that makes sense I I wanted I was I
was at a show I'm a - L is a while ago
way a long time ago way long time so I
had this show a girl her brother her
mother and father are at the show they
come up they say hi afterwards whatever
girl's hot right we're just kind of like
talking vibe in the brothers kind of
cool I say I'm going to some party at
this some club or some [ __ ] like that do
you guys want to come the girl and her
brother come to the party hmm
we're all hanging out at the party
everything's cool we're all drinking is
fine we leave the brother goes I'm gonna
go home leaves me with the time move bro
now here's the thing the father put his
daughter's [ __ ] in his brother's hands
and her in his dolt in his son's hands
bad move right cuz he was like take him
make sure he's good right
and then the brother was just like
you're on your own
right so now it's me in the girl you
probably thought you were safe probably
whatever it is we go back to my we go
back close to my place as a diner
outside of my place I'm sitting down an
eating food at the diner right and she's
eating kind of young
she likes plain like she got chicken
fingers no you know the jellies that
open up like that yeah she licked the
jelly well that's annoying
it's annoying but it was all so childish
she also order a vanilla vanilla
milkshake Happy Meals for this time cuz
I want a toy something's gonna occupy
there's no Sammy toys so she so she just
looks he's just came across one yeah I'm
like I'm like how old you and she goes
I'm 18 I got okay you gotta go home I
had no [ __ ] clue I might be a [ __ ]
honestly like I disappointed brother
dude that is [ __ ] correct but you
have if they're 17 well how many leap
years well maybe they did you HR did you
kill you kill around you got a rocket
you got a helmet and we're home bright
or as you call just a 10 for pedophilia
and I just want the flake like we should
have known and [ __ ] okay let me tell you
something
yeah I know what you're saying but I
still don't guess you will you've been
married bro but even still even still I
get young girls aren't attracted on yet
oh they're just not don't look young job
that's the thing ariana grande looks
fourteen I'm not attracted to her at all
she's probably 25 I don't even know the
[ __ ] she is she I don't
years old yeah there are girls Puerto
Rican ones that are 17 you know and they
look 20 fine oh yeah 28 they're 30
I know the other weather despite they
get a they've been through and through
it the Joker stares all alive that place
ratchet yes you went from there throwing
eggs at people Oh guys at the top of the
stairs just chucking eggs oh and you
know what drives me crazy back there
like [ __ ] tourists how dare you come
here it's like welcome to being from New
York yeah yeah like we've been deal with
this share a whole [ __ ] lives when
people say Tours in LA I'm like what do
you how do you think this town stays
alive for the first time the Bronx has
tourism and they're like bitching and
moaning about it how dare they come up
here it's like this is part of it right
you're one of the pearls are you not
yeah if you can deal with it you got
some stairs people like moved into
Hampshire if you don't like it so much
move it all out yet I forgot here go so
we go to current events you are yeah
yeah we're going to lunch in not too
long chin check 24 and a half ago
yeah chin not been here once he said
doing a Texas stuff a dad thing I
thought was my favorite part of the
episode but then I think chin checked
out when you said duck sauce that was
hard I don't wanna hear the duck sauce
part well kimchi a fish sauce maybe
kimchi it's just rotten cabbage right
fermented cabbage said yeah it's
delicious he's good for your insights
make you poop poop make you poop oh good
oh noes make me poop good man I eat that
stuff on anything shake it up kimchi
kimchi League I'll eat a bunch of
probiotics stomach yeah me die I know
with me you genius Schulz you always eat
clean right you don't need bread and no
bread know that Brian scheppers ever no
bread I mean every once in a while some
[ __ ] like piece beat the slow it just
makes me fit like I hate this like I
don't want to act like it I'm not you
eat whatever the [ __ ] you want I'm not
telling anybody eat it just when I was
even lots like bread and sugar and like
put in tons of sugar in a coffee I would
be more anxious and in our business I
don't need that I need to be as cool and
calm as I can in all situations
yeah because every single day something
[ __ ] up has happened and we have to
deal with that yeah so I just cut that
[ __ ] out and I felt way better simple as
that and it's really the American bread
when I was like away in Europe Italy and
[ __ ] you're doing yeah cuz I think it's
a little bit more
or whatever double zero is that it yeah
you've heard a double zero fine now you
can order now the double zero pasta yeah
well that's what they do that's Italy
you can order that kind of a double zero
flour they use that to make a lot of
stuff up would you what you work out
yeah you just be right oh really I think
it's tiger Shulman's tyre strohman MMA
haven't you I work out both you guys
work it's so fast on genetics you're
nobody thini me good I know that and
then you I just food genetic so I so
rude
that's so crass you're the one that's a
little pudgy lately not [ __ ] me I
know dude workout thing yes I [ __ ] I
know I know I know I know you think they
think you don't work out I don't hurt my
[ __ ] feelings I was in the gym when
you guys came down and somebody guys
doing I was there faking it yeah I was
on the elliptical with five-pound
weights fell listen you get invited
nobody invited me to the hoop game I
would support for this fighter and the
kid is brought to you by the best in
men's below the belt groom in manscaped
I'm talking manscape man engineer tools
for your family jewels jingle balls to
the walls fellas listen up on trim pubes
are a thing of the past it's time to
gear up and get yourself the gift of
shaving this holiday season I'm talking
about the manscaped perfect package 2.0
alright manscape has redesigned the
electric trimmer there's a lot more 2.0
has an advanced skin safe technology so
this trimmer won't make a snag your nut
peace no more clips on your dick peace
none of that man and don't use the same
trim on your faces used on your balls
it's 2019 but we threw on 20 what are
you doing what are you doing also this
manscaped perfect package 2.0 which is
the perfect gift for xmas for your dad
your mom your stepdad your grandma your
auntie this perfect package 100 includes
a crop preserver an anti chafing ball
deodorant all right and speaking of them
sweaty balls they also give you a nice
pair boxers manscape boxer brief that
keep your junk feeling fresh all damn
day tis the season to manscape so get
yourself your dad your brother
friends the best gift of the season
manscape perfect package 2.0 get 20% off
free shipping with code fighter at
manscape calm your balls will think you
get to himself and free shipping with
code fighter at
keep calm clean up your nuts make your
Center proud this year listen it's the
holidays man and everybody loves the
feeling of winning especially the
feeling of winning the holidays if
you're giving everybody bomba socks this
holiday you deserve to feel like a
winner nobody opens up a pair of socks
and goes I didn't want socks
we all wear socks we're the best socks
I'm talking about bomba socks they're
not just soft they're not just kind of
soft they're made with the softest
cotton in the world that's what we're
talking about extra cushioning so no
matter what you're doing walking the pup
showing that home playing the drum
saving the world maybe doing some karate
in your garage whatever Obama socks
provides the sport in places you didn't
know you needed all right you do a lot
of different things so Obama's made the
perfect sock for it like a dress sock
for work performance sock for working
out a limited edition holiday socks they
got you covered all right you know the
person who just gives the best gifts
well they're usually given bomba socks
if you want to give the gift the perfect
gift if you want to be the perfect gift
giver go to bombas comm slash fighter
today that's Bo MBA s.com slash fighter
get wimps off your first purchase at
bombas dot-com slash fighter
we're also brought to you by the one the
only the best supplements on the planet
of the earth I'm talking about on it
supplements what you need man alpha
brain shroom tech new mood
there's no excuse don't wait to January
first colonic in shape okay let's do it
new year new me stop it
start right now get ahead of the curve
let on it help you go to on it calms
last fighter they got on demand workouts
bodyweight workouts kettlebell workouts
Mase Club workouts digital do it from
your freakin phone no more excuse to be
thick I know I'm thick but take you from
your boy I'm trying to get in shape
before January 1st starts be ahead of
the curve man and doing the best fitness
apparel nutrition gear whatever you want
man on it calm got you covered on it
calm / spider 10% off
you were watching crashing like COD this
a photographer right do you remember
when you texted me that whole thing the
whole dialogue he's just babies do it
this is a bit he's no it's not a bit
dude everybody texted him the entire
script i voice word-for-word the entire
script of this is 40 yeah I do this is
40 in my top one time and I 10 I tacks
it to edit a voice text it was a long
voice it was so long and there's moments
where he would be like he would go like
this like I could hear him quietly going
direct honest [ __ ] - it was the BTS yeah
dude yeah so this was sent in from phase
rossabi and so this guy went on to
campus at the University of Toronto with
a bucket filled with liquefied poop we
don't know whether it's human feces or
animal feces but he had a bucket full of
it
well walked into the library on three
different days and flung it at people
well while they're like studying it yeah
while they're exciting study and [ __ ] I
mean what's the point
and how did he get away with it so many
times apparently he just walked in flung
some [ __ ] and left and came back two
days later and no one dated everything
they couldn't catch her who's on he's a
student uh he just walks I invited a ton
of [ __ ] he walked in with a bucket of
[ __ ] and threw it on people yes
and initially people thought it was
coffee because it was brown and then the
smell finally hit and people ran the
[ __ ] out but wait what am i understand
why is one day is this two separate days
he did this he did it on three separate
days let's say and how did they not
[ __ ] keep an eye out I got to give
this guy props so three days is dope
like one day it's like dude that guy's a
madman two days you're like this meant
he's something's wrong with him three
days you're like this guy's just having
a good time we're happy is yeah what a
one and two I think that and don't get
in the [ __ ] him we don't know has to be
his [ __ ] but that how many shits are you
taking a day I take three and that's a
lot two or three for me I'm getting one
one week we're DNA test right now they
had to take batter
his [ __ ] yeah and now they're running it
through a test to see if it's him
I don't think I don't think it's his
[ __ ] no this is like a clue who you
think he is access to [ __ ] he's got he's
got he's got another job where he I get
[ __ ] like he think he has access he
might clean like City drain city pipes
or something yeah yeah ah yeah yeah
that's actually smart whenever you got
that yellow produc reduction Georgian
half room oh let's go to the Liz oh oh
please go the okay so I'm sure you guys
have heard about that haven't seen the
out because it looks like a really long
black hole just a circle work our asses
this is a hit play for me wait what what
is this when did this happen so this is
Liz oh she's so Liz oh is the singer
what's the name of the song truth hurts
hurts mentioned do you eat you know it's
not about the attention it's it can you
pause for Sammy but if Kylie Jenner did
this well that's a thing right it's like
if you're fat you can really wear
anything and it's brave yeah you get
away with it the most interesting uh
[ __ ]
but how insulting is that it like if a
skinny hot girl did it they before they
they'd be like this is this is public
indecency it's nude a fat person imagine
imagine you wore something right and
people were like not you you're fat
they're basically saying wow you're so
disgusting that to wear that you have
courage yes right insulting her they
wear this [ __ ] with pride i'm britta now
we're okay with it because we don't
because we know that it's insulted
because they wouldn't call it brave of a
skinny girl of course I'm right all that
there's kids right my kids don't wanna
look at your [ __ ] ass kid to a
basketball game yeah but also it's the
press about me you fat [ __ ] is getting
about you enjoy the game as much yeah
you don't like my unpopular opinion as
she does stunts like this because I
think Liz Oh didn't realize how big of a
white audience she would have like white
people think Liz Oh was like there god I
love her and I
think she didn't realize that I think
she was like oh all these [ __ ] nerdy
annoying suburban whites they love Fez I
don't think she thought that was gonna
be her audience I mean that seriously so
she does these things to pop back out to
be like you white people don't really
get they don't get to get me like they
think they do do you know I don't like
they don't get to just have everything I
mean I mean that usually Graham it's
kind of like how like Lauren Hill
remember when Lauren Joe Torre's iyx
Graham for me remember Lauren Hill was
like music for white people yeah but she
mention it got it got misconstrued which
is basically said like I'd rather have
[ __ ] my kids starve than have you
know my albums bought by only white
people there's so many words but what
she was trying to say was I don't make
this music for whites like this is my
voice for everybody
she was saying to my voice is a black
woman and this is for I think she was
trying to say it's predominantly for
black people to live experience I stop
lists I'm just saying
white women think lizzo is like their
hero yo people I don't think she loves
that she's a good follow on the right
you might say you know I'm saying like
he's like if this crazy [ __ ] to be like
[ __ ] white people cuz I don't they don't
get to own me I think it's a rebellion
if there's one where she's twerking keep
going down to more like alright well I
can I get it not this one no [ __ ] no the
instagrams different because it's yours
you have to opt in but we're not we're
in that show the basketball game is just
it's just like you don't need to do that
that's what I'm saying like bro I don't
know I wanna see what you guys are in I
don't care about her sighs look I'm
being honest I don't give a [ __ ] that
she's big
I think her wearing that is just
disrespectful it's just like that's
stupid you don't do that [ __ ] it's just
stupid for no reason you know I don't
like that cool all the celebrities like
yeah you go girl like but you got [ __ ]
on Kylie Jenner in the Kardashians they
have to say you go girl cuz if they
don't say that you go girl okay I guess
look at that picture on the left if Kim
post that or Instagram you get taken
down yeah that's funny you'd be bad
you'd be [ __ ] up right away from yeah
if you showed your booty like yeah
Derrick Poston first one to like it him
would that make sides yeah he likes
booties he said that before he's this
girl this girl has the right to do
whatever the [ __ ] she wants I just think
it's nice it's a little weird you know
our face the little wire I don't like
everyone's you don't have the right to
do whatever you want you don't have the
right to work with wrong
to a club not to answer here's my other
figures if a non famous person did it no
girl would be an [ __ ] she did that
yeah yeah just dress decently at the
[ __ ] and also we don't even know the
rules you don't know the rules to the
game of course not have some respect for
the [ __ ] game but what about a little
self-discipline stop eating [ __ ] it's
just like what when do we just so much
isolate that one as well javis I got up
with the under-18 that wants to smoke
with black Twitter all the black do it's
the same thing with a theories just stop
eating when are we just like okay go
ahead dude yeah just do it let's
celebrate you just being undisciplined
and being I think she wants to rebel I
think all it is is what I said before I
think like these white nerdy suburban
moms who love her I think she wants to
be like you're not who I make music fine
I really like her and it's not a racial
like her yeah I think it's an honest
perspective her going I don't think she
likes like I don't think she wants to be
in a Kia commercial you don't even know
that she wants to know it'll be really
funny I know it's like infer this is a
bourbon whites they'll always get
criticized or just always kind of like
are tolerated by certain artists like if
they're like alright we're just not
gonna go to your shows we're gonna buy
your albums and they watch their [ __ ]
plummet by 80%
like if why people really want to say
the n-word they could really go we're
not buying your album as low as we can
sing along pitch you rappers like maybe
in the song if you bought the ticket to
my shop that's the n-word passage Rachel
last year who somebody said the 80% that
a fan on stage yeah girls he goes do you
know the lyric and she was like blah
blah n-word and all crowds like yikes
yeah but you know what he asked you to
sing the song I mean he turned on her
too afterwards yeah it was so rude who
so [ __ ] up you got your goddamn minds
thank you how about don't invite a white
girl on stage to sing your [ __ ] song
then if you know it's filled with ads
also your lyric dose at it you played
the hook you said it I don't know I
think I think that this whole little
thing is too confusing I don't get it I
feel is so though I want that well
documented you love little [ __ ] don't
love for her guys all right fans she's
all right all right
you are a white suburban mom as that is
a [ __ ] fact you know there's a time
and a place
yeah bodybuilder proposes to sex doll
after getting a plastic surgery now this
I love oh he seems legit hmm so this
bodybuilder is based out of Kazakhstan
and he says that he met his girlfriend
which happens to be a plastic sex doll
in the club a couple years ago and he
swept her off of her feet away from a
terrible relationship with a young man
with ill intentions and he basically had
this whole relationship with her and he
decided to propose there in the
limelight and she felt uncomfortable
with the way that she looked so he made
a decision to purchase plastic surgery
procedures for her to look different and
they're very much in love whoa
what a psycho dude I love this guy he's
gone on to several interviews to
proclaim his love for him [ __ ] you and
though he dress he's covered up you see
that Liz oh damn thing out crazy that
dude is your friend this is your buddy
yeah the [ __ ] would you do Matt but if
ya if you're if your boy if your boy
came to is like I gotta meet you
something dude I've been seeing someone
you're like oh do congratulations and
he's like I want you to come over a
meter straight up what would you do if
she was sitting at the dinner table what
would you do I'm being dead asked here's
well if you walked in and your buddy was
I would could not stop laughing I did
get the [ __ ] I use like dude I know this
is not traditional but I'm being serious
this is my this is my feels I don't what
would you say if you have a you can't
add a side want to look at the [ __ ]
I've never seen
I've never seen what it looks like I
haven't I want and I do want to see it
and what if he was like dude you could
[ __ ] her we're in an open relationship
I want it do they remove it I would want
my own thing I could get allowed before
I cleaned up yeah like more the hookah
has the tips yeah I want that with the
[ __ ] done yeah so I knew we got his 1
and I put in time do you know who I mean
I've got a worked out to my size yeah
these sex dolls are perfect yeah
when you think about it because they
conform this is great can we do we see
more of the things that she does ah dude
I think I like changes or wake up and
[ __ ] got him got a key fried [ __ ] oh
he's an actor too
yes doing well he's like I already have
a co-star in mind but we already casted
someone well you got on cast him oh
they're getting saxophone did she like
does she like music I don't understand
yeah yes she did
what a [ __ ] hot mess they got as a
mental illness bro yeah this is imagine
when he gets tired of carrying her the
proper way you know she was just
dragging her around there to fight war
to fight for the bridal shower the girl
on the right the girl on the far right
she gets she knows she's like this is
insane other [ __ ] are in the girl in
the far right is like [ __ ] this you know
that guy got outta here bro this is what
is it happening wrong now just one more
baby all right this one do you guys were
those fitbit's at all I don't wear that
[ __ ] well whoop a thing about to do
another thing with whoo it's our thing
you guys did for your competition right
I don't have a competition that was the
free time I'm sober October oh no didn't
you guys feel like a weight loss thing I
did this is real this can actually
really happen - I'm sure a lot of people
[ __ ] how do we know it just wasn't Jack
and I'll say it say it say that say yes
text messages I'm not text message set
it up well we got each other Fitbit
stuff right and then you're tracking
their fitness levels it was fun gift for
each other and then later on she found
out at 4:00 a.m. his heartbeat was
what crazy yeah and she wasn't going to
exercise or anything else and it's at
4:00 a.m. she knew she knew yeah she
know she's [ __ ] jacket it hard he
creates a jack in it that's why I yeah
you got yeah you got to have sex on on
your back man if you cheat your arms
gotta be right next to you say it did
you leave them around do people wear
them all yes you try you can go online
and check it how your spouse no you
leave them on all the time I thought you
know when you work out right because
it'll track your sleep yeah that's the
main reason people work for me that for
me it'd be like what are you doing it
for him your hearts by let's do I'm
having a panic attack I'm freaking but
yeah but I got to do this we yeah that's
really me I wake up at 6 a.m. like girl
I foggy dude I sleep like [ __ ] I can't
turn off the head this guy could have
got out of it
yeah but what nah nah nah he probably he
he probably wanted her to catch him
she's pretty hot who is the girl oh let
me see I see
oh yeah that's Topanga yeah yeah good
reference ah I don't know she's good I
think that's a lot of TV look watch
she'll say anything that looks like TV
she's gonna you know she's a hottie Ben
I think you guys see TV stuff look now
in their own out left let all yeah
maybe we're in life I'm just gonna see
that one right there I think you guys
ctv ctv stuff i'm not gonna work good
bit for but i think you guys see stuff I
think that looks like TV stuff it is
team she gets made up very much she's
not nothing she's an ugly I'm just
saying like you made it out to be like
she was you know no she's not [ __ ] I do
know it's not Halle Berry hey were you
not at the game the same game liz' was
once you at the game with your boy
little yeah we were to the Clippers game
where that was the Lakers game we can't
afford those tickets bro I can't sit
courtside right I would have to show my
dick or my butt to get those seats
there's like 50 G's a pop what about
that fax man they can little dick you
yeah FFX you made them what they're made
of money you know those guys no no you
know what
well cuz we got them through his
management team they have season tickets
dude Clippers Clippers
floor seats are literally one tenth of
the price
Lakers floor seats why they're the best
team well Lakers again
what do you mean why LeBron j.p will pay
whatever is to watch LeBron James in a
lake in Jersey true people fly from
across the globe just to come to LA to
watch a home game yeah and then they go
back to where their friends in things
yeah people with money to it though you
look at the Lakers floor it's it's all
foreign money because they're like I'll
pay 60 G's to sit floor side to see
LeBron on yeah because he does because
their kids might get some shoes he signs
shoes and [ __ ] and LeBrons playing into
the LA [ __ ] up that they give them to
the kids that don't need the shoes you
know where oh do come on I sat next to a
kid on the floor this this this this guy
had his kid there and it's like this kid
has no [ __ ] idea what a basketball
game supposed to be like like in his
mind he's like the waiter come a waiter
comes to you yeah like you know I mean
like the menu down there is a real food
menu it's not like dad can we get a hot
that with me was like yeah can we get a
hot dog and a coke and he was like yeah
and we'll get some nachos I like [ __ ]
and we're gonna stay them in line I
would lose it right oh the line didn't
even exist the other line aired it was
all a big one yeah but this kid sits to
his little [ __ ] dork feet not even
hitting the ground yeah like chicken
cushions see you want chicken fingers
and I want and I would like honey dijon
ya know he'd he wanted a side of fruit I
was like yeah you got a side of fruit to
call that so I lost my mind I was just
like that's what this kid experiences
for a game right but it's funny cuz they
get it's not his fault you know it's not
the kids fault and the sneakers up top
send him to the thrilled old your size
16 give it no he should have owed
[ __ ] it he should have one of the
usher guys walking walking all the way
towards it should be to the furthest
[ __ ] see those I don't know if they
deserve it more but like you need it I
need shade it more you could sell it
appreciate that kids dad could buy him
those sneakers you know what the irony
was is I guarantee you the rich kid
would sell it online you know our poor
kid would sell it oh that poor kid is
the finest and he wouldn't sell it I
think it would mean so much more yeah
because I said this last night actually
I think I was more generous when I had
no money then now that I have a pot of
money
not a ton ton I shouldn't say that yes I
have a little bit of money compared to
what I used to have I'm saying I have a
ton I was I was broke broke when I first
moved here I was so
poor really I feel like everybody's been
the same you know I didn't have money
now I was born less money in the sense
of like don't ask me being okay with
buying stuff or giving it away to people
and stuff and now and one of foods I
might lose it yeah I'm Way more for
because I'm a fear I'm gonna lose it
Anderson I'm more generous me too I was
but I'm more generous I wish I was I get
so nervous I'm like they're gonna take
it away from me
nice yeah I'm Way more gentle why I'm
worried they're gonna take it away from
me did you grow up with a lot of money
no a lot I mean we were fine we were
very comfortable my parents I owned a
dance studio I guess I guess I guess I
don't know what my anxiety stems from I
get nervous yeah oh my god yeah more
than one how's your balls dope yeah yeah
no no my parents are very calm we were
we were fine - I just feel like I went
to public school yeah we do beat us yeah
guy was probably one of the more wealthy
teens of upper class upper middle class
yeah yeah you know but um yeah my
parents had a dance studio so it's like
it's not like we're [ __ ] moment more
than one not one one dancer but my part
my parents had like a really good
business and they like understood the
structure their business they like
defined their business and then all
these other feel your business
yeah probably from them just seeing them
work tired like I guess I grew up fine
it's just I get I I guess I started this
game so poor that I could I get scared
I'm not just beaming I I gotta go I
understand that there's a fear of going
down yeah you get scared yeah and it's
like I think it's why a lot of times
athletes have come from nothing spend
all their money because they're not
afraid of nothing because they've
existed and they've thrived in nothing
yeah because because they went to zero
to a hundred we're in this game uo 0 to
10 to 20 and deck down to 10 like this
this the stand-up game but it's like
we're at zero right like you don't mind
zero I don't miss it right I don't
[ __ ] this losing a kid you don't want
to go out there I don't miss it you
never want to go to know you're the one
I'm is sharing a bathroom with three men
I don't miss that kind of [ __ ] this this
is different they'll be so heartbreaking
if we went back down to zero
be funny though it would be hilarious I
get a new hour out of it Kalin would
love it Kath would [ __ ] love it
Callan that racist bigot there's a I
think what happens is once you realize
like you can make money from nothing you
start to have less economic anxiety and
I think when you're in like the
Hollywood matrix like for so long you've
been auditioning and getting pilots and
getting shows all these things you're
like
[ __ ] I hope I get another show I hope
again yeah yeah yeah but your money is
in their hands and I think the more that
you get into podcasting and the more
that you start you know you continue
selling out in the road and doing these
things and you start going oh I'm making
my money yeah friends but be fair you
know this too this is the first time
this has happened in our industry in a
long time it never used to be this and
ever yeah so I'm saying like that's why
the nervousness is there cuz I'm like
never used to I used to yeah yeah
literally what farmers do we plant seeds
yeah and then go get the crops at the
end of the harvest right so like when
you're a farmer you have confidence
you're gonna eat because you're like I
just plant it right put in the word soil
yeah exactly guy at the grocery store
that needs to buy the pumpkins is like I
hope we get pumpkins yeah yeah I hope we
get radishes or whatever it is so I for
me I think that's what started happening
when I started when I went okay I can do
this I can create content I can put it
up in places and I can create revenue to
take care of my family take care of my
friends take care of my parents
whoever need needs money whoever needs
anything and I know I'm doing it I'm not
relying on someone else that's the
reason why I wanted kind of out of the
typical Hollywood shows like I can't
live my whole life hoping someone
chooses me well it sucks it's not your
special that cuz I think i'ma say that I
think they have other friends through
the same way like Oh anti how it anti
Hollywood not like we're specially gonna
be there all Netflix coming centrally Oh
I'm not like in it I'm not in science I
Hollywood it should I'm not saying and
timing but when if when you go against
the Machine and then soon the Machine
goes we'll take it you're like alright
do it Matt you gotta break the Machine
press one is you break the machine so
you like my nice imagine totally yeah so
it's like the new special will be I
think one of the first specials that is
like a product of new media right and
they got you know back in the day I
think the network's deserve the lion's
share the money because they had the
platform they had the audience the
audience which is most important they
had the audience we couldn't get in
front of people unless the HBO said here
get in front of people right and they
also had the ability to shoot it right
they had all those things and we were
the ones that put together the content
we still do that now we do the content
we have a play
for me that we want you to write or
Twitter Instagram all these other things
we could shoot it if we want I do it
every single weekend with my guys and we
have the people so if you want me to go
on your network the page structure got
to be totally different right it's got
to be totally different when I told
people to like put out their content for
free I don't think your contents
worthless you define the value of your
content right just cuz you put it out
for free doesn't mean it's worth nothing
no yeah yeah it's worth it so it's like
so for me I wasn't gonna do a deal
I want from nobody wanted to do a deal
to people being interested in I wasn't
gonna do a deal until the deal was right
and I'll tell you stories your ideal
yeah yeah I mean it's pretty crazy
how much I'm gonna tell you exactly how
much no no no no I'll tell you what
happened about I tell Sofia exactly
job-wise I know so [ __ ] bad okay so
this will happen I came back from a long
time ago before I came here I did
remember a drop used from the cyst and I
was here yeah I think was the first time
I ever did this one like that same time
I was here I was about to drop you since
I think it was the next week
mm-hmm I had a meeting with comi
dynamics right
you're the production committee and get
it they get new media they [ __ ]
understand it and they're K we want to
have view so missus can you not put it
out and I was like it's gonna be a
million dollars and they were like what
are you talking about you don't put it
out on YouTube I was like not it needs
to be on YouTube so it's a million
dollars if you guys want it and they're
like okay we'll just give us a few days
so like it's going up Sunday so I in the
comedy world needed it in a weird way
like the culture needed it it was just
like a big [ __ ] you and yeah just need
to shake some [ __ ] you know and then I
go to Montreal I have a good Montreal I
come back Netflix makes me an offer for
to do stand-up to do the degenerate
whatever like 15 minutes all the new one
yeah yeah okay the other doing 15 though
didn't know 15 and then I was like yeah
I put my stamp on Instagram Twitter I'm
not sure I'll do it on that and you're
gonna pay me cool yeah yeah it's no big
deal and then we get a call from comedy
dynamics and they're like hey what is
Andrew doing anything for a special my
like your Netflix reached out hmm and
they're like don't sign anything give us
a second we'll put something together so
we go back to Netflix with some demands
we know they're gonna say no about but
we're like can he be the first episode
can hit his face on the flyer just [ __ ]
that they're gonna have to run through
their lawyers to like stall for a couple
days but also legit
I don't care yeah I just want I just
thought they were really good comics
that were on this yeah and so I was like
that's cool like these are you know my
brothers and sisters like let's do
something fun
but we just need a few days so they come
back my agent comes back and he goes
okay here's the deal and he's like
really excited and he like puts it down
on the deal from comedy dynamics is for
a million dollars and I go man this is
[ __ ] amazing and I'm dude that's
that's awesome great job but tell him
we're not interested and he like had a
heart attack like my agent had a heart
attack because he thought it's a home
run
[ __ ] means like this is what you want
it and I was like no no that was for the
last special so shits changed so it has
to adjust accordingly
because I don't care but I'll put it on
YouTube just as much becoming Dynamics
is just the production company the
production company and where did they
want to live then they psyche they would
go and shop it right well we stopped it
together we put we partner right yeah so
we because what my thing with them is we
got a partner we got to be in this
together in every aspect of it creative
etc it's not just like paycheck that is
done it's like how we gonna work
together in English it good so I said
hey man I can't I you know that's
amazing but I kids got to be more
because that's what it was last time and
if I value what I do and I feel like
it's increase value then you got to
respect that and at the end of the day
I've never paid any of my bills off of
money from a special I'll put my special
on YouTube so happily yes so [ __ ]
hide some more - he's doing that I might
you know what I mean or I got some good
play conference where we're going with
it I can't say just yet but but
basically you know we sit back and and
my agent had a [ __ ] heart attack I
was he just trust me man just [ __ ]
trust me and then I dropped that crowd
work special games like 3040 minutes
yeah I was like make 35 minutes and he
was like what do you do like we have
things I'll just [ __ ] trust me
everything's fine and the crowds were
special hit a million views and then we
got the offer that was right and then we
were like Netflix thank you very much
but we're gonna go
with commie dynamics and then and then
we just settled with a place that we're
because because I don't see so it's
gonna be on see so long story so I want
to make the announcement in my space no
it's actually now it's why it's a [ __ ]
it's no it is it really interesting is
that there's a so Judd Apatow has this
it's a baseball Network they're doing
baseball and comedy and so I think I'm
gonna be the first cool dad gets the
point I'm trying to excite it for you
just [ __ ] I can't wait gonna be that
I can't wait just do like I guess what
like last time probably we were on here
and we're had these conversations and I
do believe like comics you should share
all your [ __ ] but when given the
opportunity to sell it it's important to
get your value or yeah mm-hmm you know
and I think that's why this was
important for me it was like make sure
to make sure people know that there's
there's a reason you're doing there's a
em road to all this right now we're not
we're not destroying the industry we're
just shaking it up so that we can work
together in a better way cuz we're doing
more than we did before right it's not
[ __ ] it's hey let's [ __ ] with each
other like a list all the chips yeah I
don't work for you
yeah work together look how much we're
doing all three of us tomorrow can go
film an hour and we can put it up on our
YouTube and get millions of views mm-hmm
we know our value you're right so get
paid accordingly you know and even if
you don't get paid put on YouTube and
then blow the [ __ ] up with it yeah we
got all the options yeah it's it's it's
it's a new way and it's also so young so
it's hard it's a hard it's a hard medium
I mean you've got anyway your shits
gonna be [ __ ] dope on where it ended
up on tick tock or C so it's gonna be
dope yeah yeah I want to say this all
the offensive [ __ ] up [ __ ] that we say
on here Schultz and I cuz I know Andrew
well I love him we mean none of it and
Shaab means literally I mean I'm serious
when we make jokes and we talk about
offensive weird fucked-up [ __ ] yeah
we're probably kidding around
when shops
it's real head [ __ ] zoom means it he
means a he's a is a pedo racist yeah
okay can you sign us out as the Texas
cowboy yeah let me tell you something
about chinny-chin-chin took a whole
bunch of them and I appreciate y'all
listening to the fighter and the kid
featuring the red rocket and you break
the [ __ ] industry Schultz and
good old biggity Brandon show the
bigoted Brendan Schaub the big brown
bigot Brendon shot any dates I know you
say oh you know this weekend a I've got
to I'm doing two shows at the Ice House
in Pasadena on Saturday the first ones
already done already sold out and the
second one is almost sold out but come
see me this Saturday I says I'm done
until 2020 I do the red rocket or doing
small theaters yeah go can you get the
tickets for the red rockets or Andrew
Santino com go to Andrew Santino calm
baby pulling up on one of the dates I'm
gonna check out the dates I'm you want
to come through seriously I would love
to yeah honestly I would [ __ ] love
that cuz I had so much fun when we did
our show the other self on Tony and we
should we did we did like a Q&A after we
were just [ __ ] fun man will you
seriously come up with day I'm gonna
pull up I promise you'll come to a date
absolutely especially if you're anywhere
this is all shops dates he puts it up
for shop debris cuz ESET he doesn't
remember where he is he doesn't where he
is right now so many performing at UFC
forty-eight
right now what town are we in right now
yeah yeah yeah the injured cells come
you could check out the YouTube YouTube
accomplished the end result in them I'm
on tour right now the matador tour and
you can get tickets to the special
matter of fact we're doing special in LA
at the Orpheum when April 11th and the
tickets go on sale presale is December
17th soon and the code will be Matador
for that so just go get those early man
yeah buddy go get them
love it man to the best I'm in Atlantic
City this Saturday La Jolla and all next
week in La Jolla Comedy Store get
tickets T pack a calm fellas love you
both love you man thank you for that off
cowboy thanks for listening take fat K I
love you baby
come back soon justified kid route